COUCH WARRIORS, IT'S BEEN
TWO DAYS SINCE THE HISTORIC
SINGAPORE SUMMIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND NORTH
KOREAN LEADER KIM JONG-UN, AND
WE ON THE RIGHT CAN'T STOP
CELEBRATING.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF LIMP-DICKED
DIPLOMACY, AMERICA FINALLY GOT
HER GEOPOLITICAL GROOVE BACK.
(  LAUGHTER  )
OH, CAN YOU FEEL IT?
CAUSE MY GIRL, LAURA INGRAHAM
FEELS IT.
>> EVEN WITH THE HIGH STAKES,
HIGH STAKES INVOLVED HERE,
REALLY SERIOUS, POSSIBLY DEADLY
CONSEQUENCES OF FAILURE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKES
GEOPOLITICS FUN AGAIN.
>> Jordan: YES!
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING
POSSIBLY DEADLY GEOPOLITICS FUN
AGAIN.
IT'S LIKE AN ESCAPE ROOM WITH A
LION, AND THE LION HAS NUKES--
FUN.
BUT, OF COURSE, THE LOSER LEFT
CAN'T LET TRUMP HAVE A WIN.
THEY LOVE TO POINT OUT A
SO-CALLED DOUBLE STANDARD AND GO
ON ABOUT HOW SOME REPUBLICANS
WHO LOVE THAT TRUMP MET WITH
NORTH KOREA WERE CRITICAL OF
OBAMA FOR SAYING HE'D DO THE
SAME THING.
WELL, GUESS WHAT?
THE RIGHT CAN PLAY THAT
HYPOCRISY GAME, TOO.
>> REMEMBER WHEN THE LEFT WAS
ALL ABOUT LOVE, PEACE, AND
UNDERSTANDING?
♪ ALL WE ARE SAYING
IS GIVE PEACE A CHANCE ♪
>> SO ONE WOULD'VE THOUGHT THAT
MANY OF THOSE SAME PEOPLE AND
THEIR IDEOLOGICAL OFFSPRING
WOULD VIEW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG-UN AS
A MOMENT TO SAVOR.
>> Jordan: YES!
HERE'S TRUMP FINALLY GIVING
PEACE A CHANCE, BUT WE HAVEN'T
HEARD A PEEP FROM JOHN LENNON.
WHERE ARE YOU, JOHN?
LOOK, TRUMP WENT TO SINGAPORE TO
MAKE A DEAL, AND HE MADE ONE--
APPARENTLY, A BIGGER ONE THAN WE
THOUGHT, BECAUSE NORTH KOREA IS
NOW CLAIMING TRUMP PRIVATELY
AGREED TO LIFT SANCTIONS.
AND WHAT DID AMERICA GET IN
EXCHANGE?
THAT SWEET-ASS HANDSHAKE.
PLUS PRICELESS INSIGHT INTO THE
ENIGMATIC PERSONALITY OF
KIM JONG-UN.
>> PEOPLE WERE SAYING, "WHAT'S
HE LIKE?"
HE'S GOT A VERY GOOD
PERSONALITY.
HE'S FUNNY, AND HE'S VERY, VERY
SMART.
HE'S A GREAT NEGOTIATOR, AND
HE'S A VERY STRATEGIC KIND OF A
GUY.
>> Jordan: HE'S STRATEGIC.
HE'S SMART.
HE'S FUNNY.
THIS GUY'S THE TOTAL PACKAGE.
(  LAUGHTER  )
AND IT'S TICKING, FOR SOME
REASON.
( APPLAUSE )
( CHEERS )
HE SAID AN IMPORTANT THING,
THOUGH-- HE'S FUNNY.
I MEAN, CAN YOU IMAGINE THE
JOKES HE TOLD?
A RABBI AND A PRIEST WALK INTO A
BAR, AND THEY'RE IMMEDIATELY
EXECUTED BECAUSE RELIGION IS A
DISTRACTION FROM THE SUPREME
LEADER.
( RIM SHOT )
YES!
OR HOW ABOUT: TAKE MY UNCLE,
PLEASE!
(  LAUGHTER  )
NO, SERIOUSLY, DETAIN HIM AND
THEN SHOOT HIM WITH AN
ANTI-AIRCRAFT GUN!
( RIM SHOT )
YOU GUYS, IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE A
PERSON IS SMALL, AND THE WEAPO
(  LAUGHTER  )
IS BIG.
IT'S THE FUNNIEST WAY TO EXECUTE
A RELATIVE.
ANYWAY, WE CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU TO
VISIT AMERICA, KIM JONG-UN.
I BET YOUR TIGHT FIVE AT THE
LAUGH FACTORY WILL LITERALLY
KILL.